hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday May 18th 2020 what's going
on how you doing are you doing are you
doing all right you guys believe in like
ghosts do you believe in like paranormal
[ __ ] do you believe in Jesus no do you
believe in I don't know every once in
awhile you know like I'm at one time I
got it when I was still living back in
[ __ ] Massachusetts
I almost said Beantown that's the
funniest [ __ ] ever to meet Beantown I
lived there for 27 [ __ ] years I never
found the place where they made Boston
baked beans I I never saw it on a menu
you know Beantown never saw it anyway
back in the day when I was young I was
living back there and I was coming back
from college it's a long time ago okay
and as I was walking I got off the train
the commuter rail and I was walking you
know over to the parking lot and for
some reason I envisioned smashing the
window on my truck I just had that
vision and then I you know walked like
another [ __ ] five minutes finally got
to my truck and my window was smashed
and the [ __ ] radio was gone and all
of that [ __ ] right and I was like well
that was weird how do I have like some
sort of you know I hate that my radio is
gone
do I have some sort of paranormal not
paranoid do I have some sort of [ __ ]
ESP am I like that little chicken
[ __ ] poltergeist you know what did
she say
I have exorcised the demons or whatever
I started thinking like why the [ __ ] did
I just think that right so this morning
I'm laying in bed I live out here in Los
Angeles which for the most part is a
desert and I'm laying in bed and I wake
up
in this I have this song in my head I
[Music]
can't get up that high walking
hand-in-hand with the one I love and I'm
like what in the [ __ ] is making me think
of that song so I started laughing
before I even open my eyes ik why is
that [ __ ] song in my head
lo and behold I wake up it's [ __ ]
raining outside it never rains out here
never rains in Southern California but
pours man it pours you know what is it
was that because I was sleeping and I
[ __ ] subconsciously heard the rain or
is it one of those things where they say
you know you only use like [ __ ]
twelve percent of your brain and I
somehow broke through the glass ceiling
of my own stupidity and I can sense
after [ __ ] is happening before I know
with my regular senses that something's
gonna happen every once in a while
something what is what is that [ __ ]
called you know you look at the phone
and then it rings all right you think
what is that thing it's [ __ ] weird
it's May it never rains in May we have
June gloom but it rains you know either
somewhere between November and February
out here it will rain like every day for
life it feels like for a month and then
if there's no rain for the rest of the
year then if everything gets all green
it looks like Oregon out here it's
[ __ ] incredible and then gradually it
just keeps you know the Sun every day
just dries everything out and around
August or September it all catches on
fire and then we start over again then
everybody back east looks at these
[ __ ] fires I don't is it [ __ ] you
in that bag it's like that's like
[ __ ] 30 miles away from me but thank
you for checking what is that cause
maybe I should look that up thinking
something
and then it happens what is that a
self-fulfilling prophecy oh that's night
let I wouldn't go that far
what is it called oh I think this means
like you know I'm gonna make the NBA and
then it happens I don't mean that five
things you do everyday that actually
mean you're psychic oh yeah this will
feed my ego there's a white chick with
tattoos walking with nose with their
sandals in her hands okay this is about
psychics we all have a sixth sense it's
something within you that tells you when
danger is lurking specifically when
there's something or someone around you
you know you shouldn't trust oh your
this is going with you Gunn whether it's
a new type of feeling or a general sense
of knowing something that seems to come
out of the blue people are directed all
the time to trust your gut to follow
your intuition it might sound weird to
say to somebody trust your trust your
psychic power oh boy I'm right now I'm
starting to be getting my senses right
now my sixth sense is telling me that
they're gonna try to get me to buy
something right now yes some sort of
book about psychic power at the end of
this article all right but when you tell
someone to follow their intuition that's
exactly what you're doing your personal
intuition is the guiding factor when it
comes to your abilities these five
things you do every day might actually
mean your psyche is that like that thing
like you ever see what I mean it might
be the way they cut the nature videos
right but there'll be some little
[ __ ] rodent you know meandering
around and all of a sudden Eagle or a
bird of prey will lock in on it for
[ __ ] you know god damn bravo airspace
right and the [ __ ] thing senses it
like I got a bad feeling and there's
something watching me that feeling you
get when you you think there's something
watching you all right so you these are
five things and there are conscious
efforts you can make to help her harness
your power and get in touch with the
universe ooh okay this is getting all
hippy dippy figuring out and
understanding your psychic ability is
not in cut shut up and just get to it
all right number one you think of
someone right before they text you
thinking of someone right before they
text you is actually
form of pre cognition the ability to see
or perceive events right before they
happen through extrasensory perception
or clairvoyance valerie mesa clairvoyant
astrologer and writer for elite Daly
explains at first I had trouble really
noticing a different shirt
differentiating it from everything every
other thought but but with time I
realized it was part of my clairvoyance
I simply have a thought about someone
and keep going about my business they
will either call me or text me it never
fails well I mean I could do that about
my wife
and of course she's gonna call me and
text me she's my wife this is this is
vague is that part of the clairvoyance
man it's like it's like right there but
if you reach out to touch it it moves
away man but if you just let it be it'll
sit there with you all right number two
you always look at the clock at the same
time I'm skipping that one I don't do
that
you get bad vibes from people and get
chills yeah okay that's being able to
read people you see random in you images
in your head all right what's this about
this is like the [ __ ] ring one
psychic skill that falls in this
category is called weight you get bad
vibes from people and get chills there's
a fine line from clairvoyance and just
straight-up racial profiling doesn't it
what the vibe you get some people what
about your own how good a person you are
how open you are and whatever I would
think if your [ __ ] you know
pessimistic you get that bad vibe more
so than someone who's a little more
open-minded you see random images in
your head one psychic skill that falls
in this category is called psycho metree
or taken object reading and it's one of
the easiest psychic skills to practice
though it may only come through
sometimes they the more you pay
attention to it the more often it
happens say you're ordering your morning
coffee from Starbucks there it is there
it is there it is there's the money
everybody see that I was clairvoyant
I knew it was coming why couldn't I
can't I just be sitting in my breakfast
nook drinking a cup of joe say you're
ordering morning coffee from snob
sitting on your IKEA chair um since
psychic senses are heightened when we
are most relaxed but what does that have
to do with Starbucks there's plenty of
people to make coffee you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the moment you passed your coffee
you get an image of a little girl
throwing a temper tantrum as you're
walking away you hear the barista who
made your coffee complain about the
temper tantrum her daughter threw that
morning when she left for I know I know
I don't this does not happen to me
if I started doing [ __ ] like that I'd go
to Vegas you know and I'd wear like a
wizard shirt would you be stupid cuz
they'd be like this [ __ ]
counting carts he's trying to throw us
off with the wizard shirt all right
another form of psychic skill comes into
play without holding an object dr.
parris explained there was clairvoyance
which means clearly seeing images or
pictures of the I don't see that [ __ ]
all right
I just heard walking in the rain and it
was raining up do you dream about
someone and find out they wanted to talk
No
all right maybe I'm not clairvoyant 36
Institute oh look at the cute lesbian
couple at the bottom aren't they
adorable all right what am I doing here
by the way I'm on Elite daily if you
want to see the adorable couple oh look
at this
Proctor's baffled 30-second stretch
relieves years of back pain watch they
finally have a dude you know they kept
having these chicks will [ __ ] bent
over with their [ __ ] asses in the air
and shorts going up their ass it's like
what are you doing he trying to help my
back here get me to jerk off is just
jerking off [ __ ] cured lower back
pain alright everybody this is the
Monday morning podcast and it's Road
yeah we got a [ __ ] I'm out here in
the garage and got a bunch of people in
my house getting ready moving around
some [ __ ] getting ready for the Bambino
here in a couple of [ __ ] weeks I was
hoping to you know have a few drum
things down before I get no sleep for
the next three months I'm so [ __ ]
excited to become a dad again and I'm
also nervous as hell I'm gonna be honest
with you because I know how much work
one is I'm like okay now there's gonna
be two but ever he's like no no once
they get past a certain point they can
play with each other but I got to tell
you my daughter is Russian the t-ball
crushing and she gets upset when she
doesn't like you know and I got temper
tantrum but if she only hits like a
ground ball she said God that day I want
to hit it far and it's the one thing
that I've ever found like wears her out
as I get her up there taking some cuts
and she had me dying laughing cuz she
I'm telling you she's got that it's got
that athlete thing I'm not saying she's
gonna make the [ __ ] MLB I'm just
saying she's gonna be a gamer so she
gets up to bat right and she's just
crushing these things and you know and
then she runs over she picks up the ball
sticks it back on the tee ball stand
right so I've gotten her cuz she was
kind of crowding the plate she's getting
up there like Barry Bonds but she wasn't
able to turn quick enough right so I
told him to stand further away from the
plate so one time when she came back she
was standing too far away and she took
like this [ __ ] like swung out of her
cleats swing and was right in level with
the ball
but she was too far away and she missed
it and she laughed and as I'm trying to
tell them moving closer she took like
six more cuts swung just as hard and I
was dying laughing and I moved her up
and then she crushed one and then she
went over and said she's like dad died
tired and she laid down and the grass
first time I ever saw her get tired so
it's like the greatest thing ever
because I've never been able to wear her
out she just has like battery life for
days and I would do this thing where we
play this game called rah like rah like
I jump out and I would [ __ ] scare her
so I've been playing it since she was a
toddler so she core yeah toddler so she
just still calls it raw like that dad
won't play rough
so I used to chase her around so I got
advice people saying like no you don't
want to do that before they go to bed
cuz you know you're getting their
adrenaline going they're gonna be up
longer and I was like well I'm trying to
wear her out and I could never wear her
out
so I finally found something but she hit
one I hit one and went up onto the roof
of the house and it got stuck up there
so I had to go you know we have a flat
roof on my house so I had to go up there
put the ladder up to get it so I threw
the ball down to her and I got as I was
coming down the ladder I heard her hit a
clean one and then I heard it hit my car
bounced off the top of my car and then
hit the fence on the other side which
was a significant shot for her she
cleared these shrubs and all of that
type of stuff and it was just it's the
greatest the greatest feeling ever so I
got a son coming now so you know we have
a little bit of a driveway and I'm
thinking you know when they all get big
enough you know we got to play a little
street hockey you know get the
rollerblades out there play it's gonna
be it's gonna be [ __ ] insane and once
once my daughter is a little bit older
because she's batting Lefty
and she really gets the muscle memory
down she has a great [ __ ] swing and
everything I'm gonna have her like
somewhere around when she's 4 4
1/2 take a couple of cuts from the right
side and I always try to do that like
when we play soccer I have her you know
she was soccer she kicks with the right
foot but I also have a kick a punch with
their left foot kind of get the a me
dexterous thing going and just see where
it leads
you know see if that makes her a better
athlete or whatever but it's a fun thing
it's [ __ ] that I do because I actually
go up when I take cuts on the tee ball
thing you know I take my old man cuts
and I swing lefty and I'm a right-handed
batter and I don't know I think it's a
fun thing I also I would guess is a good
thing for somebody old like myself to be
engaging a different part of my [ __ ]
brain I still want to buy that was a
Dave DeBusschere the late great New York
Knick wrote a book called the memory
book and he had an absolutely incredible
incredible incredible memory one of
these guys that was literally memorizing
the phonebook you know what by the way I
rewatched Michael Rappaport's when the
garden was eaten it's it's such a great
great great documentary and about the 70
and 73 Knicks I believe I wish to get
way that I always thought they won one
they won two in three years but I think
it was there was a three year gap anyway
I was watching that and I saw that's
what really stuck out this time when I
watched it because the first time all I
saw was Willis Reed beat up the entire
Lakers bench broke two guy's jaws and
[ __ ] was just like I was like I've never
seen that footage so that's what stuck
out and then also course young pictures
of Phil Jackson going look at that guy
he was just like a guy coming off the
bench like a sixth man and he goes on to
become arguably the greatest NBA coach
of all time I would say he's the
greatest no disrespect to read Arabic
even me being a Celtics fan there's
something about doing it in the modern
era with all of the information and
everybody has access and all of that
type of stuff it just seems like it gets
harder and harder and harder which is
sort of my my Babe Ruth argument that I
always get into you know specifically
with Yankee fans and then I just say to
him I go
right let's just look at the stat of
hitting 400 all right the last person to
do it was Ted Williams in 1941 okay
Jackie Robinson breaks the color barrier
in 1947 nobody's ever done it since but
before 1941 from the beginning up until
1941 like 27 people did it and there's a
couple of years we're like five guys did
it in the same year five guys four guys
three guys all hit and if you look it
happens every year in the beginning in
the late 1800s and then all of a sudden
it happens every two to three years then
every five years and it just gradually
trickles down and down and down and down
because people make that Babe Ruth
argument going well there was less teams
so the talent pool was higher and i 100%
disagree with that i disagree with that
you all you only had white people so the
upper echelon of white people in that
league I think the Hall of Famers the Ty
Cobb's Babe Ruth's could have played any
era but a guy like me there was a bunch
of guys and not like me but you know
what I mean there was a bunch of guys
that never would have made it past
double-a triple-a that were then
absorbed up into the MLB for the simple
fact that you know all the you know
Derek Jeter went a bit of Pedro Martinez
Josh Gibson Willie Mays all of those
guys weren't there so I always look at
it like once they opened everything up
you got the Babe Ruth of every race
showed up and that's why baseball I
think got stuck in the past until they
let everybody do everybody had to do
fucking's the modern-day athlete had to
do [ __ ] steroids and they had to
juice up the ball to break the records
of what a hundred and fifty pound guys
did you know so I don't mean any
disrespect to the stars from back then
I'm not questioning whether they could
play now I'm saying they could but I'm
just saying those other two-thirds of
white guys you know a lot of whom we
pitching [ __ ] too you know Babe Ruth
and Ty Cobb and all these guys hitting
400 and 700 something [ __ ] homeruns I
always look at like that's the stat that
I look at where it's like all of these
people hit form numerous numerous years
more than one person hit 400 in a year
and then all of a sudden after 1941 no
one can ever do it again
closest guy I think was George Brett and
you think of some of the hitters George
Brett Rod Carew Pete Rose Wade Boggs
Tony Gwynn just masta Ichiro Suzuki I
mean that dose what do you think those
guys would have [ __ ] hit okay and I'm
not saying that they would come back
with this go back in time in in like if
they went back in time we're just born
back then so it's all the same nutrition
all the same knowledge and all of that
they would have hit [ __ ] 400 they
would have they all would have that's
what I'm saying oh he's trying to start
a sports argument all right now let's
talk some old NFL all right I'm trying
to avoid all the [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
news
old NFL [ __ ] that I learned this week
all right so they don't count NFL titles
this is if you knew the podcast all
right if you've lost your sense of taste
and smell and now you're quarantined by
yourself and you listening to this
podcast welcome so here's some NFL stats
that I got I don't even having them in
front of me should I should I bring them
up so I'm tana percent accurate trying
to do the Dave the butcher things and
[ __ ] memorizing here but all right
open here we go
NFL started with NFL QB history and then
it came to this all right
so hey we yeah ladies and gentlemen
today we're gonna talk about the kicking
game in the NFL all right now if you
like me back in the day when you used to
watch you watch the old black-and-white
footage of of field goal kicking back in
the day people used to kick straight on
they didn't kick the soccer style which
came about in like the late 60s early
70s I don't quite remember
when so um of analysis come on you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
every time I try to open a window and be
smooth as I'm talking it never [ __ ]
works out I just got to get some of this
guy's stats all right so anyway when I
would watch that [ __ ] I thought that you
know because they were kicking straight
on because it always looked like they
had like some [ __ ] giant offensive
lineman kicking the ball that they were
not kicking the ball that far that was
sort of true because I just feel like
coming straight on like that
like how much weight could you get
behind it how far could you kick it it
just seemed like a an if it was a more
inefficient movement with your leg as
opposed to coming in soccer style it
seemed like you could bring your leg
back further with coming in soccer style
than you could straight on and I
believed all of that [ __ ] which i think
is essentially true because everybody
kicks soccer style now so it must be a
more efficient way of doing it but I but
as far as like people not kicking it
that far I thought that that was true
until I read about Lou Groza an original
Cleveland Brown played with them from
1946 I believe to 1967 now I have his
his Wikipedia page up here so I'd be
able to tell if this guy was 6-3 250
pounds
alright he pull he played offensive
tackle and he was their field goal
kicker so that was what you know when I
looked at the highlights I didn't
respect it the way I should have yeah he
played 1946 1967 he took 1960 off
because he had a back injury and then
came back from 61 to 67 he was just the
place kicker at that point and what's
amazing is that he served 1960 he took
off I can only imagine the rehab back
then for your back end all right let me
trying to do is a you know touch your
toes and stand up as quick as you can
here pick up this refrigerator I can't
imagine what the the rehab was
so he then played from after his back in
61 to 67 now here's the thing about this
guy he was the first guy that could
accurately hit from beyond 40 yards and
could hit a 50-yarder and up until Lou
Groza came along like the kicking game
was really overlooked by everybody in
the NFL it was all about you know for
the most part running the ball in or
throwing the ball scoring a touchdown
and kicking the extra point was like
whatever but nobody really took into
consideration that you know field goals
missed field goals and all that can
really like they just didn't have the
stats and all of a sudden and also
people couldn't kick it as far as Lou
Groza so Lou Groza comes in and could
kick the ball a country mile as they say
and this is Kate he was basically the
first Adam Vinatieri okay because the
Cleveland Browns were in the All
American Football Conference the for the
entire four years that that league
existed 46 47 48 49
all right the Cleveland Browns won all
four of those league championships and
then you might say to yourself well
built it wasn't the NFL so those
championships don't count fine whatever
I get it
1950 the Browns joined the NFL and guess
what they did they won the NFL title and
went to the NFL title game six straight
[ __ ] years winning three of them and
what people did well they were like what
the [ __ ] are the Browns doing you got
Paul Brown you got Otto Graham what else
is going on they started crunching
numbers and they realized that the
Cleveland Browns during that time won
15% of their games because of their
kicking game and they understood didn't
understand that you know the fact that
they could drive down to like I mean
back then if you could be--could the the
the field goal posts were right on the
goal line so if you got down to the
40-yard line
just ten yards into the other teams or
mid field right now 40 40 40
two yardline right you were in lo loo
grooves grosses range and he would come
and he would kick and in fact in 1950
when they played the NFL title game with
seconds left on the clock he went out
there and kicked it right through the
uprights to win it and they asked him
afterwards they said Lou will you
nervous he said no I knew it was going I
knew I knew I was gonna make it this guy
had the championship gene right so he
ended up let's see well how many points
this guy had he ended up like this is a
tight end to so these were all like
field goals he had like 11 1200 points
at the end of his career his career
point total was 1603 part of those 1349
were in the NFL counting his AAFC years
his career point total is 1603 they
actually had something called the Lou
Groza rule you know like this is the Mel
Blount
rule I'm kind of into that [ __ ] like
rules named after football players the
Lou Groza rule he had this thing where
he would come in and he would put a
piece of tape right behind the ball like
just like a straw almost like a piece of
duct tape or something like that which
just sort of helped him line his foot up
when I went through it's not like he did
anything to the ball or anything like
that and he was just crushing it so much
they said okay you can't do that anymore
and then you know what he did he
continued to kick another thousand
[ __ ] field goals but he was the
original Adam Vinatieri Lou the tow
Groza you should know this guy he played
for the great Cleveland Brown teams he
won three and half for NFL titles 1950
back to back in 54 55 and then they won
in 1964 and then he also won for All
American Football Conference titles so
that's eight titles by the great Lou
Groza he is the he is the reason that
the kicking game is so important today
isn't that cool if you're a football
nerd alright
football rules named after players
that's hilarious it said named Lou
like my computer's not listening to me
the bill belichick rule the Bronko
Nagurski rule the Ken Stabler rule
that's the [ __ ] you can't fumble the
ball forward the Emmett Schmitt rule the
Greg Pruitt rule the Hines Ward rule the
Lester haze rule that's stickum Phil
Dawson 11 rules named after named after
people all right here we go
this is what a great [ __ ] topic this
is all right the Bill Belichick rule
since 1994 NFL quarterbacks have been
permitted to wear speakers in their
helmets enabling coaches on the sideline
to communicate plays to them without the
use of hand signals beginning in 2007
lime green stickers were used to mark
these are the [ __ ] sorry just moved
these radio equipment helmets during the
2008 offseason the NFL passed a rule
that allowed one defensive player on the
field to wear a speaker in his helmet
the season before Bill Belichick and the
New England Patriots were fined for
videotaping a game against the New York
Jets from an unauthorized location in
order to learn their defensive ads at
Spygate their defensive hand signals if
you didn't have any hand signals it
wouldn't have happened former Dallas
Cowboy head coach Wade Phillips said of
the spigen I'm just happy to get
something passed the way you don't that
way you don't have to worry about people
were putting towels up in front of
people
you shouldn't have to play football that
way
the Patriots voted in favor of the
proposal yeah basically everybody would
this is what the SPN didn't say
everybody was [ __ ] doing it and then
in 2007 they passed a rule that you
cannot [ __ ] do it that was the first
year you couldn't do it and then the
Patriots continued to do it and we got
busted although the way this is written
they're making it seem like nobody did
it which was [ __ ] so I don't know if
that's 100% accurate because I did the
research on that because they were
coming after my [ __ ] team and by the
way I know all you guys who [ __ ] hate
the Patriots those [ __ ] nobody did
it
only the Patriot right while you watch
all of these college football games and
is when they're holding up signs they
got a picture of a slice of pizza
Arkel the sign for pie and there's some
guy breakdancing in pop lock and it's
like why do you think they're doing that
it's because people are stealing signs
and I've always maintained that if you
think stealing signs is cheating then
what you should do is have America
forfeit world war two
alright Bronko Nagurski rule oh by the
way I got a great one on the New York
Football Giants listen to this [ __ ] or
should I continue with this I'll
continue with this then I got a great
one on the Giants who are one of my
favorite franchises of all time the way
I hate the Colts I love the Giants I
love the Giants they come out they hit
you in the [ __ ] mouth they win the
[ __ ] game if they lose they go home
the Colts they come out you hit him in
the mouth they cry they make it a
they change rules it's just really the
difference between the two you gotta
beYOU have one is run by men and the
other is not alright number two Bronko
Nagurski ruled the Bronko Nagurski rule
was enacted after a controversial finish
in the 1932 NFL championship game
between the groose Keys Chicago Bears
and the Portsmouth Spartans young
Portsmouth Spartans at the time a
forward pass was only legal if it was
thrown from at least five yards behind
the line of scrimmage after new grocery
was stuffed twice on runs up the middle
in a tie game he took a few steps back
and threw a pass to reg Grange for a
touchdown portsmouth coach argued that
who grew ski wasn't five yards behind
the line of scrimmage when he threw the
pass but the call stood and the Bears
went on to win 9 to nothing the
following sees yeah if he only took a
couple of steps yeah he would have been
what do you think he'd be within it
depends on where the [ __ ] he was oh man
that way I wasn't late go hey everybody
got all upset the following season the
league declared that a forward pass
could be made from anywhere behind the
line of scrimmage
all right the Ken Stabler rule 1979 the
NFL enacted a rule in response to a play
during the 1978 season that became known
as the Holy Roller the rate is yeah
they're gonna lose the game Ken Stabler
was getting sacked and he as he went
down he just rolled the ball towards the
end zone and then I forget who it was
like Dave Casper he was trying his best
to pick it up and he just kept
accidentally kicking it further and
further until it was across the goal
line and then he fell on it with five
seconds left at this iridescent
remaining the remaining the Oakland
Raiders trailing the San Diego Chargers
by six point Oakland quarterback Ken
Stabler dropped back to pass from the
San Diego 23 yard line for an apparent
last-ditch effort into the end zone
Stabler was pressured however in an
effort to avoid his sure sack
intentionally fumbled the ball forward
the ball rolled took all I'm sorry
Raiders fullback Pete Banaszak who
kicked the ball forward to tight end
Dave Casper Dave Casper dribbled the
ball into the end zone before falling on
it for the winning touchdown
the resulting rule which is informally
known as the Ken stable rule or rate or
rate or rule prohibits an offensive
player other than the the player who
fumbled the ball from recovering or
advancing a fumble on fourth down or any
other a knee down in the final two
minutes and a half and another offensive
player and if another offensive player
recovers the ball it is placed back at
the spot of the fumble and by the way
going back to that Belichick [ __ ] it's
like also if you film people it's not
like they're just miming passing and
handing it off you would then go in
halftime and then you would have
somebody look at all the videotape and
then watch the plays and you'd be
looking at the signals and you would try
to figure out something and maybe it
would give you an advantage on one or
two [ __ ] place ok I'm just bringing
it back down to earth it was cheating
they were guilty of it they did break a
[ __ ] rule but that is not why they
won all those [ __ ] titles if it makes
you feel better you can say that but you
know ok I don't know but if you're gonna
do that then you kind of have to do that
with everybody and at that point the
Steelers immediately go down to two
Super Bowls and who the [ __ ] wants to do
that you know what because the other
team they were playing was also [ __ ]
doing some [ __ ] which is why you
have referees and then what then you
then you're gonna reward it to the
lesser team that was also cheating but
didn't win I don't get it
alright Emmitt Smith rule in 1997 the
NFL enacted player conduct rule 12
section 3 article 1 which prohibits a
player from removing his helmet while on
the field the rule was informally named
after Smith the Hall of Fame running
back who had a habit of removing his
helmet to celebrate touchdowns including
after the TD he scored on his first
carry of the 1995 season quote I had
just come off a serious injury and all I
read about was how I supposedly had lost
a step that I was on the downside of my
career Smith told them Dallas Morning
News I went 60 yards my first carry and
my hands string didn't pull I was
excited
so the NFL was like wait a minute Emmitt
Smith is having too much fun
Smith was flagged for removing
helmet during the first season that the
rule was enforced is it a badge of honor
Smith told the Austin american-statesman
no it's not know that a rules named
after him he was such a class act you
got to love him at Smith one of the
toughest guys to play to that game he
played that when they needed to win a
camera it was a playoff game but he had
the separated shoulder as a running back
I mean just with NFL running back taking
NFL hits on a separated shoulder unreal
all right number five the Greg Pruitt
rule Cleveland Browns running back Greg
Pruitt was one of the owners several NFL
players who wore tearaway jerseys during
the 1970 oh man that's like who was that
guy used to play for the [ __ ] Buffalo
Sabres he was one of their fighters it
was the funniest [ __ ] he had like tear
away [ __ ] pads and shirt and he would
go he would go to fight Tie Domi and all
of his [ __ ] clothes would just tie
would grab him and his [ __ ] would just
come off and then the the other dude
would be [ __ ] hanging on to ties
[ __ ] Jersey and what's he supposed to
hang on to his [ __ ] chest hair and I
got to look this guy up see this is how
I go down the rabbit hole buffalo
enforcer tearaway Jersey who the [ __ ]
was this guy
it all comes up to Buffalo Sabres Jersey
come on man all it says is Greg Crewe it
Buffalo let's see
NHL alright I got I'm gonna put tied
domi why the [ __ ] is it
rob ray rob ray
Ray had like you know it was like he was
a male stripper you just look at his
jersey in his jersey and his pads would
come up and then he would be shirtless
she had nothing to hold on to and then
he would just grab your Jersey and beat
the [ __ ] and this is great clip of tide
domi in the penalty box yelling at rob
ray like making these gestures talking
about his tearaway Jersey and Rob braids
just goes like oh and three saying Tie
Domi was Owen three against him
it's [ __ ] a layer I love the NHL back
then all right so let's get back to the
rules here I apologize to none Americans
and non [ __ ] sports fans here alright
so Greg Pruitt or tearaway jerseys
during the 70s as a sneaky means of
shaking off would-be tacklers right but
he never wanted Championships so he's
not going to get trashed like Belichick
Pruett rushed for a thousand yards for
three consecutive seasons from 75 76 77
75 to 77 for it to be effective you
couldn't wear anything under it Pruett
told Cleveland Magazine it got pretty
cold playing on the lakefront the league
banned tear away jerseys in 79 prutte
was named to five Pro Bowls and won a
Super Bowl with the Raiders in 1983
Hines Ward Rule in 2009 the NFL enacted
a rule that prohibits Blind Side blocks
that come from the blockers helmet forum
or shoulder and I was just the Green Bay
game the rule no no no that wasn't Green
Bay was playing a game and I remember
Warren Sapp it was way behind the play
and he nailed some offensive lineman
with you know that could have been some
[ __ ] the offensive lineman was doing him
during the rest of the game or a
previous game you never know you never
know but then when somebody gets hurt
they just look at the incident so who
knows I'm not saying anything bad about
Warren Sapp the rule is informally known
as the Hines Ward rule after the
Pittsburgh Steeler Y receiver who
established a reputation of for leveling
unsuspecting defenders and broke Keith
rivers jaw with a vicious block in 2008
I got to see this [ __ ] hit
Hines Ward who did he hit look at my
[ __ ] bad memory already Hines Ward
Keith Rivers Keith Rivers you guys would
tell me right now you're not looking up
this [ __ ] hit alright here we go
playing the Cincinnati Bengals no love
lost here oh I don't care about your
solar [ __ ] cigar-lighter that's not a
thing everybody before you go to look
for it all right there we go
why can't I hear it alright so I guess
he's gonna throw Roethlisberger
play-action fake shakes off a tackler
[Music]
that was a great [ __ ] block Hines
Ward getting some pay but oh my god that
was a linebacker dude I didn't know
Hines Ward played like that what the
[ __ ] oh wow he hit him right in the jaw
with the crown of his helmet okay you
know what that's a really good rule
that's a really good rule and also
respect to Hines Ward that all these
guys that were [ __ ] him up over the
middle he had a chance to [ __ ] hit
one of them back and he did wow that was
a linebacker too that was no joke
all right let's to Hayes rule Lester
1981 the NFL banned the use of stickum a
sticky substance used to improve grip
that was popularized by the Oakland
Raiders if you ain't cheating you ain't
trying the Oakland Raiders cornerback
Lester Hayes during the 1980 season
including the playoffs the substance
helped Hayes haul in 19 interceptions
all right all right let's let's it
didn't help him that much jesus [ __ ]
christ
well 19 interceptions is pretty [ __ ]
ridiculous but I mean he was also an
incredible [ __ ] corner anyways he
said you practically had to pry the ball
loose from him whenever he got his hands
on it
Raiders linebacker Ted Hendricks said of
Hayes in 2007 interview with ESPN well
maybe it helped a little bit I don't
know I would say you got an extra 2 to 5
all right Phil Dawson rule
during a 2007 game in Baltimore Dawson's
unusual 51-yard field goal led to the
adoption of a new rule
Dawson's kick which tied the game was
initially ruled no goo no good as the
ball deflected off the left upright and
down off the stanchion support behind
the crossbar before bouncing back over
the crossbar and into the end zone oh
that's like a hockey goal the puck went
all the way over came back out it's a
goal but the NFL didn't have that rule
at that point while replaying rules did
not have allow for the review of field
goals at the time officials reversed the
call after a brief discussion on the
field the Phil Dawson rule enacted the
following season allowed for field goals
and extra points that hit the crossbar
or uprights to be reviewed
oh so that's all it is so it wasn't a
question of whether it crossed and then
bounced back out wait how the [ __ ] could
it do that wait a second the ball
deflected off the upright down off the
stanchion support post behind the
crossbar before bouncing all the
stanchions support posts the thing that
comes down to the ground not the
crossbar it hit that and then bounced
back out that's [ __ ] wild all right
Ricky Williams rule ok but you have to
take your helmet off during an interview
you can't make the sign I'm smoking a
joint to the camera there's a lot of
rules here the Ricky Williams rule which
was enacted in 2003 declared that a
player's hair was an extension of his
uniform and therefore a fair game for
tacklers the rule was initially named
for after Williams the Miami Dolphins
dreadlocked running back it's probably
not a coincident that most NFL players
with long hair play defense but
defenders aren't entirely safe from the
dangers of hair pulling in a 2006 Kansas
City Chiefs running back Larry Johnson
dragged Pittsburgh Steelers safety Troy
Polamalu down by his hair after an
interception the dude had hair johnson
said of his tackle what do you want me
to do
[Laughter]
Polamalu has since insured his hair for
$1,000,000 so what if somebody pulls it
though he [ __ ] gets a million dollars
I don't get that all right Roy Williams
rule
Polamalu by the way one of the greatest
[ __ ] players of all time I loved when
he would time the snap and just jump
over the line and [ __ ] tackle the
quarterback as he was trying to hand the
ball off the [ __ ] guy he's the only
guy ever Sutter can consistently do that
or did it enough times that when I think
of him that's what I think of Roy
Williams rule okay the rule banning
horse-collar tackles in which a defender
whips a player to the ground by grabbing
the back of his shoulder pads it's
really behind the neck isn't it I mean
that's what you can get your hands in it
isn't formally named after Dallas
Cowboys safety Roy Williams was enacted
before the 2005 season I thought they
got rid of that way back in the 80s or
90s Williams broke Terrell Owens ankle
and also ended uh ended the season of
Musa Smith and Tyrone Coleco up that's
how you say his name with the horse
collar tackles in 2004 I play by
whatever rules the NFL lays down
Williams said after the rule was enacted
if there's a type of tackle that's legal
I'll use it if it's not legal
I won't it's as simple as that yeah it
wasn't illegal now it is now I won't do
it great answer Williams was suspended
for one game in 2007 after being flagged
for his third horse-collar tackle of the
season all right well he didn't really
back up the talk but you know his heart
was in the right you know it's a
bang-bang play all right number 11 Tom
Dempsey rest his soul New Orleans Saints
kicker Tom Dempsey was born without toes
on his right foot and wore a modified
shoe with a flattened and enlarged toe
surface Lou Groza also had a straight
toe on his kicking foot all right
Dempsey booted an NFL record 63 yard
field goal to beat the Detroit Lions in
1970 in 1977 the NFL enacted a rule that
required any shoe that is worn by
player with an artificial limb on his
kicking leg must also have a kicking
surface that conforms to that of a
normal kicking shoe all right so you
can't have like the front of your shoe
look like one of those tackling sleds in
1956 the Lou Groza rule banned the use
of artificial aids for kickers Groza a
Hall of Famer for Cleveland used a strip
of tape to line up his kicks and a
specialty to help guide the ball off his
foot well I mean they didn't have tees
back then and he beam went out and he
made his own I mean what the [ __ ] he
gonna do that still doesn't make you
kick a 50-yarder you still have to
[ __ ] do it because I could kick that
law for that T all the [ __ ] time all
forever and I still wouldn't hit one
alright so anyways let's get back to the
Giants thing then I'll and immersed
mercifully in this Sports Talk Jesus
Christ I've done up almost 50 minutes of
talking sports here sorry guys it's a
pandemic I mean I'm [ __ ] I'm
quarantine e here what am I supposed to
do
so alright let me ask you guys a
question when you guys think of a
franchise that lost the big one alright
consistently lost the big one and it is
a part of their franchise like DNA that
this team gets there and then loses
there's a lot of people on Lake Erie
right now hanging their heads and I'm
not talking about Cleveland Brown fans
I'm talking about the Buffalo Bills the
Buffalo Bills are viewed and when you
talk when you need a reference Chris
Rock made a reference to them you know
you won't get any [ __ ] until the Bills
win the Superbowl
I believe was the joke so they are the
modern era because they lost four Super
Bowls in a row 90 91 92 93 they lost to
the Giants the Redskins and then back to
back tack right so they - who did they
take them
monkey they took the monkey off the back
of what team the 1980s Denver Broncos
who lost in 86 88 and 89 blown out in 89
right so they still would have been
considered losers but not as bad as the
Buffalo Bills and then also the fact
that the Broncos Elway and Terrell Davis
those great teams went back-to-back in I
believe what was it 97 98 seasons right
but still everybody looks at Buffalo
because they lost four in a row the
Broncos lost three and four years and
the Broncos kind of took the spotlight
off of the Minnesota Vikings the
Minnesota Vikings lost four Super Bowls
I'm doing this for America's Super Bowl
for they lost to the Chiefs then they
lost one of them to the Vikings it
wasn't the perfect season that was the
Redskins lost and Gary a premium almost
[ __ ] that up with whatever the [ __ ] he
was trying to do so I think they lost
Super Bowl four Super Bowls six maybe
and then they'll uh well Cowboys won
five seventy seventy one it's cowboy 72
was the perfect season 73 so probably
seventy three and then 74 they lost to
the Steelers on LC green one had the
gold high-tops and then they lost to
their raid is on the 76 season Super
Bowl 11 so they from Super Bowl four to
Super Bowl 11 they lost four so they
were considered they couldn't win the
big game the Dallas Cowboys was
considered they couldn't win the big
game just because they went they lost
back-to-back two NFL title games one in
the Cotton Bowl and one in the Lambeau
Field the Ice Bowl that was 66 67 but
the biggest like disaster if you were a
fan believe it or not was if you were a
New York Football Giants fan in the 50s
and 60s
all right the New York Giants
the New York Giants won the NFL title in
1956 okay and then they lost the NFL
title the title game championship game
the original Super Bowl they lost that
game in 58 59 61 62 and 63 okay by the
way the that is that is one two three
four five they lost five Super Bowls in
six [ __ ] years and I feel bad for why
a tittle because he came over from the
49ers which were historically a losing
franchise at that point he joins the
Giants who won in 56 61 62 63 he loses
all of those games I just feel bad
because his last name was tittle and
knowing the New York Post they probably
called him after 63 why a no title
tittle loses again being [ __ ] about it
but they were also they went up against
the [ __ ] you know Bart Starr and
Vince Lombardi back-to-back years
there's no shame in losing to that and
then they lost to Gayle sayers and Dick
Butkus bears on 63 so there you go then
this is the last football thing this has
just been a football podcast here's one
for you in 1946 the New York Football
Giants got two players got busted taking
a bribe to throw the championship game
it was at the Polo Grounds they were
playing the the Chicago Bears now why
they got bribed I don't understand
because the Bears were the team of the
decade having won the title in 1940 41
43 and 46 43 there's an asterisk because
I believe that that's you know World War
2 had started and you know they would
combine that pittsburgh steelers
combined with like the [ __ ] eagles
they were the steals and i want to say
they also combined with the chicago
cardinals at some point or i don't know
what it was [ __ ] nuts but anyway some
gangster or somebody working with the
gangster bribed to the they're both
their defensive backs and somehow word
got out
before the before the game and they
actually the mayor of New York summoned
the two quarterbacks to Gracie Mansion
on the East River where they where the
the mayor lives or at least did I
remember when Giuliani lived over there
I don't know if he brought the Gracie
Mansion back but it's pretty [ __ ]
cool brought him over there and in Adam
Cohen separately just like when you were
at school and you and your buddy got
busted and then the principal would
bring you in one at a time because he'd
be out there sweating wondering if your
friend was gonna [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
up and admit to whatever the [ __ ] it is
you did so they brought the first
defensive back in and he he was just
like I don't know what you're talking
about it's you know it's [ __ ] I
don't want you talking about
All Right see you later your honor your
mayor hood and he leaves and then the
other guy caved and he admitted that he
did it now I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened it seemed like they found that
out before the game but all I know the
end of the day is they still [ __ ]
lost 24 to 40 n-- i don't know what the
[ __ ] had spread was but once you take
money from a gangster man i don't give a
[ __ ] if you're talking to the mayor or
the president you're not gonna [ __ ]
be covering as tight as you would have
so so there you go
but for some reason the NFL doesn't talk
about those so we I still have to listen
about the 1919 White Sox which for some
reason they call the Black Sox it was a
Chicago White Sox and I gotta listen to
them how they almost ruined the [ __ ]
MLB and they needed Babe Ruth and to
build a custom stadium for Babe Ruth to
bring the [ __ ] game back and all of
that [ __ ] these guys here when the NFL
was in a very precarious situation
coming out of World War two the college
football game was still bigger I believe
horse-racing and boxing was still bigger
than pro football at the time and these
two [ __ ] [ __ ] took the goddamn
money - I can't call the [ __ ] cuz
I don't know maybe they were getting
[ __ ] over and pay who the [ __ ] knows
all right III take that back strike that
from Mecca these two players for the
Giants agreed to throw the [ __ ] game
and you never hear anything about it so
there you go there's a little bit of
[ __ ] NFL history for you people a
little bit bill
a little bit with 55 minutes into this
podcast all right let's do a couple of
reads here for the week when the [ __ ] is
it
buffalo Lou Groza Texas reopening that
was something I wanted to talk about mm
podcast content all right okay when to
wear a mask oh wait I got to read the
advertising first right maybe I'm wrong
here do I have no live reads I have no
live reads all right well that's easy
all right well you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna do the
reads real quick all right here's a guy
here giving me the reads for the week
the questions for the week all right
when to wear a mask now this person is
this is official CDC infos below I have
thousands of our research all right so I
don't know if he's telling me this [ __ ]
this is a lot of stuff I already [ __ ]
knew but if you okay Billy no eating ass
during a pandemic BRR all right if you
are by yourself or anywhere you are not
within six feet of someone in your clean
car or house yard or on a walk by
yourself etc and you don't touch public
surfaces and your face and you wash your
hands regularly a mask does nothing for
you and is unnecessary I mean that's
pretty much common sense maybe the hard
surfaces of public surfaces isn't common
sense anyways the virus is only spread
through droplets breath saliva sneeze
cough sweat or any human fluid that exit
the infected person including
asymptomatic and recently infected
people and make it eventually and make
it eventually via transmission into your
body eyes mouth nose ears bloodstream
all right Cove it 19 so that reality is
if you have a mask on and somebody
sneezed into your ear you'd be [ __ ]
I'm Cove in 19 and many viruses and
bacteria that's what I'm from that
information so don't take that as a rule
but it seems that way
all right Cove it 19 and many
and bacteria can live for a long time on
hide surfaces 24 to 72 hours all right
so that's one two three days that have
been that have not been disinfected so
if you're doing anything around people
less than six feet especially if your
job requires human interaction or even
if you are shopping and you will touch
any public surfaces a mask might stop
you from touching your mouth or nose or
help someone or help some if someone
coughs by you yeah but I guess it could
still go in your eye or into your
[ __ ] here the CDC does not recommend
wearing a mask a n95 mask or a mask at
all unless you will be in a public space
with people within six feet of you there
is ZERO scientific evidence to support
the virus spreads outside of these
criteria fuzing fussing with the mask
counts is touching your face wear a
cloth mask when you should do not wear
one when you don't need it and yes I
work in the industry of stopping
infectious virus bacteria and pathogens
I have thousands of hours of research
and dozens of the latest scientific
studies to support this information so
don't at me [ __ ] with me I don't know
what wash your hands don't touch your
face and shut your mouth then go [ __ ]
yourself official CDC information below
love the podcast and keep up the great
work all right there you go so that's
coming from someone within the goddamn
business so everybody should also here's
them everybody's [ __ ] on people in
LA like driving while wearing masks like
I said a lot of those people I would
think our uber drivers if someone had
just gotten into that car and they just
got out or you don't want to keep taking
it on and putting it off and touching
your face you just would [ __ ] leave
it on or you're running a bunch of
errands you're getting in and getting
out of your car you don't you know
you've touched surfaces you know you're
using your antibacterial you don't touch
your face you [ __ ] leave it on people
all right come to Columbia dear William
writing from coat
Cali Colombia what writing you from Cali
Colombia the capital of salsa and
beautiful women I've been a fan since my
undergrad years in Boston some 15 years
ago you have made me laugh in some of my
darkest moments so thank you for that
now that I have been back in Colombia
for a year I would love to go to
Colombia I'd love to go to South America
I mean it's arguably some of the most
beautiful people the typography it's
it's incredible it's just always so
deceiving how far away it is because not
only is it [ __ ] you got to fly so far
south you actually have to go I like the
west coast of South America lines up
with the East Coast of America and I
live on the west coast here so say hey
it's a crazy flight okay now that I've
been to come back in Colombia for a year
I realized you have quite a fan group
here get the [ __ ] out of here have you
ever considered touring Latin America
yes you know who's gonna do it is Tom
Segura I heard Tom Segura bilingual Tom
Segura is gonna do a monster [ __ ] to
was gonna or I think he's gonna put out
weight I'm gonna shut the [ __ ] up here
because I don't want to [ __ ] I don't
want to [ __ ] let the cat out the back
god dammit I'm gonna text him and make
sure I'm before I post this so if you're
listening to it I'm night you know it
was common knowledge before this [ __ ]
I would dude I would [ __ ] love might
bring my wife down there pup but then a
bowl but then and this night that's my
white guy understanding that you guys
all listen still the girl from M pnina
which I know you dumped so go [ __ ]
yourself I'm just giving you [ __ ] here
in Bogata our capital I hope I said that
right you would easily sell out a four
to five hundred seat venue hey I'm
taking a loss on this trip Jesus Christ
I got to fly 14 hours to play in front
of 400 people I'd still do it just to go
down there because whatever I would make
on the gig would pay for the the flight
then I got to bring my wife and all the
[ __ ] bags yeah I'm gonna take a bath
on this one a lot of people watch your
stuff please do not believe the
portrayal of Columbia
in narcos and all that mafia [ __ ] you
and your family would love it here
delicious food some of the warmest
people you'll meet and one natural
wonder following the other let me tell
you something you people are so goddamn
good looking down there I don't give a
[ __ ] if that narcos [ __ ] was true I
would still go down there smoke a
[ __ ] Cuban cigar god knows they're
probably most of them are fake down
there - let me tell you something
signore what happened with mr. what I'm
supposed to say
I will [ __ ] come down there when this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] over abso-fucking-lutely
I will do that and I just need somebody
down there to tell me where I can get a
real Cuban cigar alright I don't want to
go all the way down there and just I
don't want to deal with that [ __ ] and
not I mean it's in smoke a fake one
alright cuz I told you the last two real
ones I smoked was in [ __ ] Tel Aviv
kind of [ __ ] life am i living that I
get to travel and meet all of these
beautiful I'll tell you none of [ __ ]
beautiful people Israelis I'm telling
you telling you beautiful people in Tel
Aviv okay and not to start some [ __ ]
here the Palestinian chicks what
beautiful - alright bunch of beautiful
[ __ ] people over there there we go
look at me I would love to do that
besides you would be the first ginger in
Colombia since the English Pirates tried
to rob our land and rape our women some
500 years ago I don't want to show up
and I got their back I know
I don't I know but I don't understand
we're raping I just don't understand
rape I mean that's like fishing in a
stock pond I mean where's this
satisfaction it you know wouldn't you
know talk some [ __ ] see if you can
[ __ ] make it happen the [ __ ] he gonna
do after you do that to somebody walk up
and slap a [ __ ] ice cream out of some
little kids hand why do they put rapists
in jail they should just [ __ ] kill
him anyway so you know California is
open to so you know California is open
to hey you ginger coastal [ __ ] listen to
the Thursday rent may 14th on Wisconsin
opening up and wanted to let you know
city boy city boy LA asks know that we
also have fat asses already sitting in
bars and restaurants in the great state
of California yeah I realize that but
not LA most people forget California is
more than just San Francisco in LA but
up in Gold Country we are open for
business no I understand that
and I made fun of that too didn't I or
did I not oh the Oasis there was one up
there the way they said we are an oasis
of CO vid
there's no covet here listen you [ __ ]
touchy [ __ ]
I didn't mean to trigger you I am
rooting for Wisconsin I said I was
rooting for him but this is a comedy
podcast I just did [ __ ] 55 minutes
NFL stats somebody has to take a hit
here all right I know you enjoyed your
Sacramento area shows why don't you
drive your ass up here I don't know
because I'm murder Mountain I'm joking
I tried to do a show in Eureka and then
somehow it went away
Kove zero Cova deaths 100% small
businesses beautiful this time of year
and you wouldn't have to leave your
state from a fellow redheaded German
Irish [ __ ] you know what I'm gonna look
into that who the [ __ ] am i I got a kid
coming in like two weeks my wife's not
gonna let me do that you're just gonna
leave us in the middle of a pandemic
she sounds like Jerry Seinfeld when she
gets upset with me she'd be right and
then what I'm I'm just gonna drive up
there and stop at all these [ __ ] gas
stations where all these dirty digits
have been punching in their [ __ ] zip
code for their [ __ ] I could still do
it right I just come up like I don't
need to wear a mask at a gas station
pump as long as there's nobody else
there but all I know somebody just left
there and sneezed or some [ __ ] gonna
pull up on the other side of the thing
you know I just wear them and I wear the
were and I wear the gloves you know
that's it and then when I'm done with my
gas I take off the rubber gloves and
then I [ __ ] I opened my door handle
and I make sure you know my fingers
their way in the gloves so they didn't
do that I open it up with [ __ ] two
fingers then my wife sprays me with the
disinfectant did today and I get back in
the car and I've gone that's how I've
been doing it and you know what I've
been symptom free all right all right
tough times dear bill of sale I own a
small to mid-size business in Baltimore
I employ 12 part-time employees I'm
sorry gonna be heartbreaking to read
this we opened up our shop last week and
have maintained a safe environment for
patrons while also increasing the
chances of not having to shut down for
good which sadly has become a reality
well I'm rooting for everybody in your
situation my wife's cousin told her on
the phone last night that we were
selfish which is fine as long as my kids
have food and I can pay my monthly
health insurance bill you can call me
what you want I think there are a lot of
people judging unfairly
and it doesn't seem like anyone in
charge or on television cares no because
they have money I laugh when you
hammered Wisconsin last week because it
was funny thanks for the laughs through
all of this PS I'm black and if I fail
that's one less black business owner so
if all these work shamers want to talk
about socio-economic and justice look at
the fact that we can't all work from
home yeah it's true
like something's gonna I think the big
thing now is that first email if that
was correct that information and this
person actually does work from the CD
you know does work I mean I don't know
they just said that they did
I didn't vet any of that if everybody
really knew what the [ __ ] they needed to
do to prevent the spread of it I think
that like that's what needs to happen
and then all these geniuses who are
going to come up hopefully with a cure
you know I think that that's what we're
gonna gradually work towards everybody
needs to be educated so I would suggest
going onto the CDC website podcasts like
myself and that I would be definitely
would not be looking at like that's 100%
accurate information because I just read
something from someone who declared that
they do all this [ __ ] and for I don't
[ __ ] know so I would listen to what
they say educate yourself go to their
website and all of that and then
hopefully we can slow this thing down
and then when they gradually open
everything up I mean that seems like
right everybody's just patient you stand
there you obey that six feet rule you go
in when you can go in and then I also
suggest you know as much as you can if
you can afford it to buy stairs a toy
store you know there's a toy store in
Mammoth California that's been there for
like 40-something years that we got to
know just from going you know we had
some friends out there and all that and
there's a nice strip of stores in
Mammoth California that I would like to
order some stuff from just because I
heard that you know that they're really
hurting and this is like the thing that
I don't want to see go away because it's
bad enough that there's so many [ __ ]
Walmart's and these giant [ __ ] places
that have knocked out because it's such
if you Google Earth it and you just go
down this street you'll just see it's
like it's like it's what downtown's used
to look like and it's what the Walmarts
and all those things destroyed but
something new always does come along and
then destroys the old thing but I don't
know it's it you know there's always
just something cool I don't mind either
one I don't mind a superstore and I
don't mind a mom-and-pop I think there's
a world for both and in which I just
know that the super stores can ride this
[ __ ] out way longer than the other ones
so I would hate to see that happen
because Mike's I have not had good
experiences doing business with
corporations they just they are so
[ __ ] broken that they consider
stealing from you
this is how business is done and they
sit there and they say it with a
straight face and then when you audit
them or you call them out on what
they're doing they actually have the
nerve to say that they're insulted by
the quiet by I'm insulted by these
questions well of course you're insulted
because you can't answer the questions
because it's gonna expose you for what
the [ __ ] you're doing you piece of [ __ ]
sorry anytime I bet I've gotten in
business with any sort of [ __ ]
corporation I they've stolen from me
I've then had to audit them
I've always the every time I bought it
we always catch them stealing it's
[ __ ] unbelieving it's just like it's
not business it's done we're just gonna
steal from you we know you're gonna
audit us then we're gonna debate the
audit and we'll end up you know giving
you what anything from sixty to eighty
percent of what we really owed you so
we'll still be plus forty or twenty
percent on the stealing side and then
they come up to you and smile it was so
great great performance Lulu they're
just soulless [ __ ] people and I have
no problem [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
that's just what it is so that's why any
you know we're not saying everybody that
owns a small business is a saint either
I'm just saying anyway
all right food bill if you could walk
into any restaurant right now in any
city and order any meal and casually
coffin to your sleeve on the way out the
door without anyone losing their [ __ ]
what would it be oh wow let me see here
oh that's a good one
my first thought
to go back to Boston and get some
[ __ ] Chinese food I'd go there with
my lovely wife I get some crab rangoon
we'd get the whole [ __ ] poopoo
platter the chicken fingers the duck
sauce all of that you know just
delicious heart attack no nutrition in
it you're hungry 20 minutes later coz
your body sifted through all of it and
found no nutrition I think I would do
that
that's if I was on the East Coast out
here in LA I would take my wife to one
of my favorite burger stands out here
Bill's burgers maybe I would go there I
have a couple of spots for burritos this
is something I used to love to do and
then hated myself in the morning back
when I was drinking there was a couple
of food trucks out here and I would be
[ __ ] shit-faced and I would come home
and I would stop at the food truck right
and you know which is always tricky with
the uber guy right you were like all
right can I buy you some but you'd have
to like try to time it you know cuz you
don't want your [ __ ] food to get cold
or whatever but also you know I'm not
gonna drink and drive so I would always
go up and I would get I'm a [ __ ]
chicken burrito order that's my [ __ ] and
then what I started to do was I was like
I'm just this [ __ ] white dude that
knows nothing about Mexican cuisine and
all I ever order is the [ __ ] chicken
burrito so then when I started to do was
I would order the chicken burrito and
then I would pick something by the
picture that I had never tried before
and after drinking all the booze the
beer and then shots of booze I would
then eat that stuff and then go right to
[ __ ] in bed and I would just have my big
doughy white stomach the next day you
know and then I wouldn't notice I would
just be doing that [ __ ] and then all of
a sudden you know there'd be
some sort of something where I had to
wear a suit some sort of event and all
of my suits I do this on purpose
are tailored for in shape me so I try
them on and then I can't button him like
[ __ ] and then it just makes it
makes me lose weight the worst thing
that you can do to yourself and the
length of your life is to let out your
pants in your suit is to go and buy
bigger [ __ ] clothes is to start just
wearing sweatpants and track suits
everywhere you go even though I love
wearing that [ __ ] you have to be careful
because you will not notice you won't
notice that you're putting on weight
until somebody says something and
usually that's about 15 pounds in and
who the [ __ ] wants to have to lose 15
pounds on up alright alright other songs
bill last week you talked about more
than on the Thursday throwback song on
the Thursday the throwback song was
wholehearted by extreme I hadn't heard
that song in 20 years maybe I've had it
stuck in my head all week oh I haven't
heard that song in 20 years maybe and
I've had that song stuck in my week oh
stuck in my head all week sorry guys
Jesus extra bad today it got me thinking
about bands that were known for one song
but had another great hit that was
forgotten maybe this can be a segment
can you think of any off the top of your
head yes I can the first one that popped
into my head
it's funny is I don't know they're hit I
would say is Night Ranger Night Ranger
songs let's see here so everybody knows
sister Christian right and I always
liked don't tell me you love me I always
thought that that was a better song and
then if you looked at a loverboy
everybody everybody is working for the
weekend everybody liked that song I
liked lucky ones bad babe okay babe Babu
Babu but I like that song
ac/dc everybody listens to you shook me
all night long right and if you listen
to that album
have a drink on me honey what do you do
for money
I just [ __ ] I don't I can't tell if
they're way better songs they just
haven't been played to [ __ ] death
everybody look plays highway to hell and
I always like I like get it hot or if
you want blood
the whole power rage album is gold
what's that song in the second side I
always play drums to it I always listen
to drums so I never listen to lyrics
long looking for a fingerprint
what's next to the moon love that song
and then everybody Judas Priest's
everybody you got another thing coming
I always liked desert plains which by
the way I was gonna do a benefit for
them before all this [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] happen I was gonna do a benefit
for Glenn Tipton I believe he had you
know some health issues going on and he
started a charity and it's just like I
love doing [ __ ] like that for people
that gave me like the amount of
happiness in my teenage years because
there was a band called Judas Priest
that was making music you know so now
I'm in a position where I can do my
little [ __ ] jokes and maybe help out
someone in the band and we just really
seem like a great thing to do is
something that I want to do when all
this [ __ ] is over so you know
there's a number of things I got to do I
got to do that I got to go get some
Chinese food in Boston and I got to go
do a show in Colombia look at this all
right let's go back here so you guys
tell me that's a great question
everybody I want to know like you tell
me what like the best songs are wherever
he's like oh my god everybody like
because you can be like a radio fan and
then you like the deep cut fan so
basically what you're asking for is is a
deep cut okay Aerosmith Aerosmith
there's a good one
everybody knows everybody knows the hits
all right let's just go favorite album
all right I like oh this is tough
they're their first four albums so I
would say they everybody okay and the
first album everybody listens to dream
on I like that moving out we all live on
the edge of town where we all live ain't
a soul around I like that one and then
on get your wings let's see oh lord of
the thighs I'm going from memory here I
just know all the drum beats I'm singing
the drum beats and I'm trying to
remember SOS is a good song and what is
the one she's a woman of the world and
God she knows it
[Music]
I just love the breakdown I love Joey
Kramer's drumming in that I love his
drumming in general but I just loved
that that it just it's sort of weird
hits and then he can always comes back
used to [ __ ] me up trying to play it
these weird accents and he would always
come back I always you know I put the
kick on too instead of on one I did I
would always end up [ __ ] it up and
then I would say on on Toys in the Attic
oh that that great triplet fill in the
began but dad again uncle salty I always
loved the the drum fill that went into
that and then I also loved the chorus on
the Bell and then on the Tom's I just I
love
Joey's Drummond on that and then oh yeah
and just on Toys in the Attic but then
when he does he does the crash symbol on
the end of one in the end of three I
think and he still hits the back beat on
the snare to keep it going sort of a
Phil Rudd thing before Phil Rudd came on
the scene right around the time his
[ __ ] son such great drumming and then
on rocks is what is that song something
walking on Gucci c'est la raw barely
stay on cuz I'm so goddamn god whatever
that [ __ ] sign it's the first song
second side you know unless you've got
it digitally I don't want the [ __ ] I
could kind of do that for every favorite
band of mine
Iron Maiden all day that's a great that
great topic like I'm gonna hear from you
guys let me know about those ones all
right 80s videos hey Bill I thought you
might get a kick out of these videos I
like watch I like watching old PSA
promotional videos for some reason and
here's one called shake hands with
danger it's from 1980 it's about working
safely around heavy machinery but the
way it's narrated and scored is really
funny
alright I'm gonna post all these the
next is a music video called pump iron
the song is about a guy who hates his
job and gets bored and irritated easily
so he goes to the gym constantly to work
out his stress there's a part in the
song where he basically says my family
is pissing me off and I have too much
work to do around the house so [ __ ] it
I'm going to the gym I'm not doing it
justice but I think you'll like it
are you [ __ ] kidding me that some of
the greatest lyrics ever written just a
couple of things for you to fill your
time while you're in lockdown if you
want thank you for the podcast and
everything you do you keep me out of my
own head at work and a for a few hours a
week and that makes a big difference
alright no worries I got a I got a wait
a minute I need to post both of these is
what I need to do alright that is the
podcast I got a check with segura don't
forget to do that alright
all right thank you everybody for
listening I hope some of the old NFL and
covin information was helpful
send me your songs give me some deep
cuts to your favorite bands and I know I
have way more than that cuz I would
almost I would listen to the radio and
like the band would come on like why the
[ __ ] are they always play in this song
why don't they play this give this other
one a [ __ ] chance all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday